first of all how long have you lived
here my father or second generation
Refugee I'm a third generation and my
grandfather first to live in 1948. what
does it mean to be a refugee Refugee
that that's a long story you know
Palestinians that became a refugee in
1908 when you know they lost their
Homeland they became refugees a lot of
them live in Jordan Syria Lebanon and
everywhere in Palestine you know
Palestines get divided to West Bank Gaza
East Jerusalem Jordan Valley do you have
hope for peace in the region of course I
do have hope because nothing lasts
forever you know you know what that
means nothing lasts forever we are not
alone we have a lot of solidarity from
the Jewish Community from the Christian
Community from the whole world but
something does something to do with the
governments and politicians they are you
know trying to control over one state
equal rights equal system because Jewish
Christians and Muslims they have always
lived together during the British
mandate during the ultimate's time for
decades the only hope for people to live
peacefully together it's related to one
word which is occupation if occupation
ends there's no reason for bossing us to
fight it's no reason for us against the
two rockets but people I think they have
a legitimate try to resist on a CM
people in general their nice people not
what the media says about us
you know it's crazy when you resist they
call you a terrorist it's a crazy world
that we live in it we are in the 21st
century and we still occupied so one day
that's why again I said like I started
saying nothing lasts forever exactly
eventually this occupation will end and
I do believe that history is repeating
solved but seems to me people they
didn't learn from the history you know
right
people who get the power they want to
just keep
going up you know but at least we are
not alone in this damn world